what's going on everybody welcome to the
ninth monte carlo video
uh so now that we've got this far we
found out that bettors are
not necessarily allowed to go under zero
but we're not showing it very well
when they go bust so let's go ahead
and fix that now because it's kind of a
big deal that we kind of want to see
that visually
so let's go ahead and fix that
so the first thing we want to do is
we're going to visit our doubler better
and what we're going to do is let's see
if the previous wager was a loss what
we're going to do is we're going to roll
dice
the wager is going to equal previous
wager times 2
so we'll come here and then we'll say if
value minus wager
is less than zero wager
equals value so this way
we will only wager what we have left we
won't be able to wager
into the negatives so we were allowing
this to kind of occur before
and now we are not allowing this to
occur
and we basically need to do the same
thing right down here as well
um so there so this was a loss as well
so in both the win and loss we want to
make it clear what our wager was
so now what we'll do is
up here where it says zero we'll say if
value
is less than or equal to zero
uh we do this and
then what we're going to do is let me
think here if rule dies
l so if value down here
i think we're all set so lf
previous wager is a loss
and instead of doing this here
what we'll do is we want to put this
let me think
well we definitely need to make this e
less than or equal to 0 there
and before the break we really want to
append
this stuff so
let's just cut and paste this here
although i think that would just break
that if so this doesn't really matter
let's go ahead and run this now
uh and let's just run doubler better
simpler better uh where is simpler
better hiding it
instead of less than zero we'll do less
than or equal zero
and he's that's really all we had to do
to change him i'm pretty sure
oh i think we were oh okay we didn't put
too big of a number
okay so now we can a little better see
the people that
uh go end up going to zero
yeah so that looks a lot better so we
can see how many people actually go
broke
uh because before we were actually being
able to visualize
uh the amount of people that went
actually went broke so now we can
now while we're here the only thing i
would want to change at this point
is to add one more parameter
to our better so for double or better
let's add
color so and we'll take this color
and we'll put it in here because we
might want to use multiple versions of
doubler better and stuff
so for now we'll put in color um
and then we'll do the same thing here
simpler better
color variable instead and then when we
go to plot
instead of k it's color and then here
we do double or better with cyan
simpler better okay so that should work
let me run that again just to make sure
that we did what we wanted to
okay cool and then obviously
our pretty similar uh end result here
we'll close out of that so that's going
to conclude this video in the next video
what we're going to do is
a little bit better comparison of
simpler
simple better versus our doubler better
just to see
and then we also want to look at
not only do we want to look at you know
life expectancy but we also want to look
at profit chances
so anyways that's what we have to look
forward to as always thanks for watching